much the White House has yet to announce
a single policy reform that it supports
but says President Trump is considering
ideas members of his administration have
said they do not see systemic racism and
policing Ben Tracy has that part of the
story from the White House we've done a
lot for the black community and we've
done a lot for all communities
surrounded by black radio hosts and
supporters Wednesday President Trump
touted his administration's record when
you look at the economics when you look
at how well the black community has been
doing under this administration nobody's
done anything like we've done but even
one of his own supporters conservative
activist Sonny Johnson pushed back on
the president's characterization I'm
probably the most trumpet out of
everybody in this room so you guys and
you guys have to forgive me the black
community is not doing okay
like I understand the perspective and
the result the desire to put out this
talking point but it's not okay the
President did not respond to that Thank
You senator and he and his
administration continue to oppose
allegations of systemic racism in law
enforcement
[Applause]
despite nationwide protests calling for
police reform the president has yet to
say what if anything he would like to
see done to address the issue of police
brutality and even with army leaders
saying they are willing to discuss
renaming ten US military bases named
after Confederate generals including
Fort Hood in Texas and Fort Bragg in
North Carolina President Trump says he
won't even consider it retired Major
General Dana petard told CBS News the
names always seemed insulting to him
these ten generals fought against the
United States Army and killed US troops
President Trump is planning to resume
his campaign rallies next Friday in
Oklahoma they've been on hold during the
kovat pandemic but it's not clear how
the campaign plans to do that safely and
last night vice president Penn's posted
and then deleted this photo of him
visiting campaign headquarters dozens of
staffers are seen in close quarters and
nobody is wearing a mask this goes
against the social distancing guidelines
of the White House coronavirus task
force which the vice president heads up
his office has not explained why the
photo was taken down Anthony then Tracy
at the White House thank you